seems to me that the supposedly the
smartest and most educated people the
people who go to Harvard and Yale who
run our government and run our media and
our newspapers that they actually get
everything wrong and they don't have
real world experience and they will do
anything to hold on to power and to hold
on to the basic idea that they are
pretty much better than you but this
cannot work anymore it does not work
anymore and and it cannot continue any
longer because we see what happens when
they get power and when they defund the
police and when they take charge of the
economy and when they're in charge of
covid policy and all of those things
they actually literally make the quality
of your life worse so let's go back to
the beginning to the birthday boy
Governor Ron DeSantis mocking the people
who have those useless college degrees a
lot of these students are going to go
through no debt and many of them will be
making six figures within just a couple
years the truck drivers are making that
immediately once they go uh so let's
just look to see where the opportunities
are and you're not any worse than
anybody else because you didn't get a
four-year degree in fact think of all
the people that had four-year degree in
Zombie studies with a hundred thousand
dollars in debt and then they end up in
a job they could add at a high school
you look at compare someone that goes
into electrical they're making 75 80
grand then they're making a hundred
grand then they start their own business
in their mid-20s and they start making
you know really significant uh income uh
there those are good pathways
the point of that really is that there
are other ways you don't have to play
their game which is believe what they
tell you to believe go to the schools
that they tell you to go to get the jobs
that they want you to get there are all
sorts of other ways to do it and if you
do it outside of the system yeah the
system will not be kind to you but I
suspect you will find more meaning and
happiness and joy and be surrounded by
better people than these cartoonish
clowns